hi everyone today we're going to talk
about chromosome pairs but first i've
got a question for you between a black
mulberry plant a guinea pig and a human
being which organism do you think has
the most chromosomes the mulberry plant
has green leaves and delicious berries
the guinea pigs are adorable tiny
mammals with multiple body systems
and humans have incredibly powerful
brains and the ability to form complex
social relationships before i tell you
the answer let's learn a little more
about chromosomes chromosomes are
structures that contain an organism's
genes and genes are the units of
heredity pass from parent to offspring
that affect an organism's traits
chromosomes
and the genes they contain
are located inside an organism's cells
in multicellular organisms the
chromosomes are found within the cell's
nucleus many species have chromosomes
that come in matched pairs for example
here's an image taken with a microscope
of chromosomes from a typical human body
cell the chromosomes are laid out in an
organized way allowing us to see that
humans have 46 chromosomes which can be
organized into 23 pairs each of these is
a pair of chromosomes this is one
chromosome
and this is the second chromosome
these paired chromosomes are called
homologous chromosomes
homologous chromosomes have the same
size and shape they also contain the
same genes in the same locations
remember
an organism's genes affect its traits
genes often come in different variations
called alleles
different alleles of a gene can cause
different versions of a trait
in an organism a pair of homologous
chromosomes may have the same allele for
a gene or they may have different
alleles for a gene to help us understand
this let's take a look at an
illustrative example using pea plants
pea plants can have pink or purple
flowers these colors are determined by
two different variations or alleles of a
single flower color gene pea plants have
a copy of this flower color gene on each
of two chromosomes in a homologous pair
a single pea plant may have two copies
of the pink allele two copies of the
purple allele or one copy of each the
color of flowers that the pea plants end
up with depends on how the alleles
interact but we'll cover that in another
video an image like this one of an
individual's chromosomes lined up in an
organized way is called a karyotype
scientists and medical professionals can
examine an individual's karyotype under
the microscope to see if they might have
a genetic condition this could show up
as size differences between chromosomes
within each homologous pair or the
presence of an extra chromosome
now that you're a little more familiar
with chromosomes let's return to the
question i asked at the beginning of
this video
between black mulberry plants guinea
pigs and humans
which organism has the most chromosomes
any guesses
the black mulberry plants do these
plants have a whopping 308 chromosomes
guinea pigs come in second with 64
chromosomes and like we said earlier us
humans only have 46 chromosomes so we
come in third
are you surprised believe it or not
humans with their big brains and complex
social structures
actually have far fewer chromosomes than
many seemingly less complex organisms
are black mulberry plants more
complicated than we perceive
perhaps
and perhaps there is more to
understanding the world chromosomes play
in determining traits
that's it for today thanks for watching